when in the autumn of 2010 i was the  chief prosecutor working with doreen  lawrence  to finally get a prosecution of the two  men that murdered stephen  boris johnson was writing an article in  the telegraph declaring a war  on traffic cones  and when this country was threatened by  terrorists who were trying to bring down  planes with liquid bombs  i spent the summer of 2010 helping to  put those terrorists behind bars  where they could no longer pose a danger  to british citizens  and whilst i was doing that  what were you doing mr johnson  you were writing a piece  defending your right  not to wear a cycle helmet  conference it's easy to comfort yourself  that your opponents are bad people  i don't think boris johnson is a bad man  i think he's a trivial man  i think he's a showman  he's a showman with nothing left to show  he's a trickster who's performed his one  trick once it said the words  get brexit done  his plan  ran out  there is  there is no plan